♪ We're gonna make some brownies
and probably gonna eat them ♪
♪ They're gonna have hot dogs in them ♪
(record scratch)
No, they won't
- Courtney is a chef.
She's also one of my best friends
and she's written so many cookbooks,
worked in incredible famous kitchens,
and we're so lucky to
have her on this show
making Elizabeth's food.
- Let's begin, shall we?
(upbeat music)
One of the things that I love
about your taste specifically
is that you've found a way to take things
that are memories of my childhood,
things that I loved as a
kid, but then you elevate it
and make it into something
where I feel like
it's cool that I'm an adult.
(laughs)
Like it's an adult version. (laughs)
- Yeah!
- The adult version of
the things I really want
'cause I had it as a kid.
- Speaking of which.
- Okay.
- So I'm about to make peanut
butter chocolate brownies
with Shoo Shoo and Alice.
These are the brownies
that kind of brought them
together in the show.
- They play a very large role in the show.
- That's right.
It's something that Elizabeth
makes for Mad for her lunch.
- I'm really interested to
see how they're gonna do.
I think they're gonna
be really great bakers.
- I can't wait to find
out what's gonna happen.
(squeals)
(upbeat music)
- First, before we even get started,
I would love to hear just a little bit
about your characters on the show.
- So I'm Mad Zott
and I'm the daughter of the
main character in the show.
- What do you need?
- I'll get the flour, you
go to the butcher counter.
- Mm-hmm. Copy.
- But nothing too lean.
- Oh, of course.
- And what about you, Shoo Shoo?
- I'm Amanda Pine and I am
her best friend in the show.
- Correct!
- Yes.
- And in real life.
- Yes
- And in real life?
- Yes.
- I didn't know that.
- We know each other.
- That's amazing.
- Amanda!
Mom, can Amanda come over today?
- Alright, let's start.
Let's start with the brownies.
- Alright, let's do this.
(all laughing)
- Okay, so the chocolate
peanut butter brownies
have two parts.
We're gonna make the chocolate part first
and then we're gonna go make
the peanut butter part, okay?
- Okay.
- Alice, do you wanna be the
official stirrer for this one?
- Yes.
- Okay, whisk that together.
Alright, now, you keep stirring
and I'm gonna pour in the butter.
So this is melted butter
and it goes just like that.
- That smells so good!
- Yeah, and it's gonna taste so good.
- It does smell good.
Oh, it's getting bunched up.
- Yeah, so if you wanna
switch to this, you can.
It's a little bit thick.
You're gonna have to
put some muscle into it.
- I'm gonna get some muscle in here.
- Get some muscle.
Alright, Shoo Shoo, are you ready?
- Yes.
- We're gonna crack the eggs
into it while Alice stirs.
(egg tapping)
Have you ever cracked an egg before?
- Yes, many times.
- You're an old pro. Look at that.
Alright, so you're gonna add the eggs.
- In you go, eggs.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God.
- And you keep stirring.
Don't stop stirring.
This is a very important part.
- You mix it.
- It's getting really gooey.
- Here, can I show you a little trick?
- Yeah.
- Sometimes, this is called
folding if you scrape like this,
and you can just-
- Ohhh, fold. You fold it.
- And then you can just
like get vigorous.
Vigorously stir.
- Okay, vigorous.
- Yeah.
Yeah, get vigorous.
(upbeat jazz music)
It's time to add the flour.
Shoo Shoo, would you
like to do the honors?
- Yes.
- Just don't dump it in all at once.
Kind of sprinkle it in
a little bit at a time.
Perfect.
- Keep mixing.
- Yeah, keep mixing.
So do you all like gooey brownies
or do you like cakey brownies?
Do you have a preference?
- I like both, really.
- Gooey.
- Both?
- Yeah.
- Well, I like a warm, gooey brownie.
- Yeah, me too.
I'm a gooey person myself.
- Alright, that means
that we all like gooey.
- Yeah, we all like gooey.
- We all like gooey.
- That means you put less flour in.
Because the more flour you
add to the brownie batter,
the more cake-like it'll be.
- Ah.
- So this recipe is very gooey
'cause it hardly has any flour in it.
That looks great.
Let's set this aside.
Now that the chocolate batter is finished,
let's move on to the peanut butter.
- Yes!
- Sound good?
♪ Peanut butter ♪
Which do y'all like better,
chocolate or peanut butter?
- [Both] Chocolate.
- Alright, so you stir
and you're gonna add the
powdered sugar, just like that.
What do you think makes
best friends best friends?
What is it about it?
- I think that you've
got to be friendly, kind.
You've got to be loyal
and you have to stand up for each other.
- Yeah, and be supportive.
- Yeah.
- You know what? I forgot something.
I forgot the butter.
I'm gonna pour the butter in, okay?
- Okay, pour in the butter.
- You know what else?
Friends can make mistakes
but they can still support each other.
Like forgetting the butter
we're still gonna make it work.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Perfect, we have...
- Oh, that's fluffy.
- ...both of our batters made.
Now we're gonna spread it into the dish.
- Gotta get the excess.
- How are y'all feeling?
How are you feeling
about everything, so far?
- Peanut butter.
- You feel peanut butter?
- This is making my mouth water.
- Well, I smell it.
- Yeah.
- It's making my mouth water.
- Okay, so I'm gonna put
half of the batter in
and you're gonna spread it out.
- Okay.
- And it doesn't have to be perfect
'cause as it bakes in the oven,
it'll make the chocolate
and the butter spread out.
- Okay.
- Alright, it's peanut butter time.
Just like a half a scoop, yeah.
And then just scoop it
down, just like that.
And let's plan- let’s do like
one here, one here,
one here, one here, and one here.
(upbeat jazz music)
We're gonna put more chocolate on top
and then we're gonna swirl.
- Let's swirl.
- Swirl, swirl.
- Look at all of these swirls.
- Oh, my God, you're
doing such a good job!
- Thank you.
- This looks perfect.
I'm gonna go ahead and
put these in the oven.
- Okay.
- And we will eat all of the batter.
- Oh, yeah.
(upbeat jazz music)
(bright music)
- So while the brownies are baking,
what's your go-to breakfast?
- Crepes.
- Crepes?
What's your go-to breakfast?
- Pancakes and hash browns.
Those are really good.
- Just like classic American breakfast.
- Yeah.
- I'm on board with that.
- Butylated hydroxytoluene.
A good rule of thumb
is not to to eat foods
that share ingredients with jet fuel.
- I'll add it to my vocab list.
- I smell the brownies.
Do y'all smell 'em?
- I smell 'em.
- I think they're finished.
Ta-da!
- (gasps) Oh, my God, they look so good!
- They're perfect!
(bright music)
Now, this is a little trick too.
This is a professional trick.
We made these so they would
be like little lifters.
So it'd be really easy to just go plop.
(Both gasp)
Plop, and there you go.
So now, it's really easy
to just cut and eat.
- That looks great.
- Okay, here we go.
- I don't believe in plates.
- Yeah, who needs plates?
- Who needs 'em?
- You hear us plates? We don't need you.
- Alright.
- Here we go.
- Let's see if this is any good.
- Let's see.
How did we do?
- Mmm!
- Oh, my gosh, they're so gooey.
You can tell there wasn't a ton of flour.
- They're so gooey.
- They're so good.
I should get paid in brownie.
- I think that can be arranged.
Thank you all so much for
joining me in the kitchen today.
I had so much fun.
- You're welcome.
- And you can see more of
these characters and recipes
in "Lessons in Chemistry" on Apple TV+.
- Thank you.
(bright music)